[Music]
to my stay
on this last day I was thinking about
turning it around
because I was going to say that I could tell
the truth that nothing came out for me it
is blocked as I am not here now
it
is still very difficult for me after
so many years
of doing my whole life
I was not here I was not ready today I
have to say goodbye to this
as I said before there were many years
in my life that I arrived when I was very
young at 13 years old
after
21 years
I am going with my wife with three Catalan
Argentines
and I could not be more proud  from everything
to what I did and lived in this in
this city to which I don't have
to be away for a few years we are going to
return because in our house